[Música]
i
no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nosotros nos embarcamos en una historia
para transformar este 70 80 por ciento
que es lo que generalmente se ve de
gente que no toca un instrumento musical
nos metimos en la historia de cómo
transformar este porcentaje a un 70 y 80
por ciento de personas que sí tocaron
instrumentos musicales
y precisamente lo que nosotros empezamos
a buscar fue cómo logramos transformar
el paradigma del aprendizaje
instrumental
todos hemos escuchado acerca de la
importancia de la música en el
desarrollo del cerebro en el desarrollo
y sobre todo desde etapas tempranas hay
gente que ha dedicado años de su vida a
entender cuál es este impacto de la
música sobre el cerebro humano gente
como universe en el instituto de
investigación rotman ha metido años y
años de trabajo para entender cuál es
este nivel de precisamente de impacto la
música trabaja en el cerebro humano a
nivel positivo frente a la creatividad
impacta en la coordinación en la
motricidad en el lenguaje y sobre todo
en la sensibilidad entonces que puede
ser de un niño que no tenga una acceso
integral a la educación y el aprendizaje
instrumental puede ser un niño que el
día de mañana tenga ciertas dificultades
por ejemplo para aprender un segundo
idioma o puede ser un niño que sea
absolutamente disperso en sus
actividades diarias y sobre todo y lo
más importante pues un niño que no tenga
sensibilidad humana
nosotros decidimos
investigar este tema el desarrollo
instrumental y la importancia del
aprendizaje instrumental si nosotros
entendemos que precisamente la música
tiene este impacto tan positivo en el
cerebro humano porque será que la
dejamos como subvaloradas por ejemplo
desde la educación entonces empezamos
una investigación cualitativa para
entender qué sucedía a nivel de
aprendizaje instrumental que era lo que
estaba sucediendo con el aprendizaje
instrumental desde hogares y desde los
colegios
y encontramos tres problemas
fundamentales el primero de ellos
es que los instrumentos musicales no
tienen esa etapa de progresión y es el
proceso de aprendizajes que tienen
algunos otros objetos
por ejemplo imaginemos la motocicleta
qué pasa si subimos a un niño de 8 años
en esta motocicleta se va de cara pero
este niño ha tenido un proceso de
aprendizaje uno un proceso completo
alrededor de entender cómo funciona este
objeto entonces de peso con el triciclo
luego se subió a una bicicleta como
todos ustedes con las lean ticas atrás
un día le quitar las antillas de atrás
se fueron de cara un par de veces pero
finalmente un día lo entendieron la
aceleración el equilibrio y un día se
logra se lograron subir en la
motocicleta en la música pasa algo un
poco diferente entonces en este lado
tenemos el instrumento musical de
juguete y el instrumento musical
profesional gracias y el instrumento
musical profesional entonces que
teníamos acá en este centro teníamos una
brecha de aprendizaje una oportunidad de
diseño cierto
así que nos embarcamos en la historia de
empezar a encontrar este problema y
analizar alrededor de este problema el
segundo aspecto fundamental el segundo
problema que encontramos fue hoy ya no
hay un instrumento que le permita a las
personas experimentar alrededor de las
tres tipologías precisamente para que la
personita que empieza a tocar encuentre
algo que nosotros denominamos la
identidad instrumental sino que cuáles
son las tres familias de instrumentos
musicales de cuerdas vientos y
percusión precisamente no hay un
instrumento que nos permita encontrar
nuestra identidad instrumental y el
tercer problema que encontramos fue oiga
cómo hacemos para replantear algo que
siempre ha tenido ciertas dificultades y
es el proceso de aprendizaje tan
estricto que nos proponían los métodos
tradicionales por qué no pensar
alrededor de la lúdica y de utilizar
nuevos elementos cómo sería el color con
las escalas de grises así que
todos estos elementos todos estos
problemas nos llevaron a pensar ya
diseñar ya desarrollar un instrumento
musical híbrido que combina cuerdas
vientos vientos y percusión y toda una
metodología precisamente alrededor del
color y de las notas musicales es un
sistema que
busca transformar el paradigma de la
educación instrumental precisamente para
construir una sociedad más sensible más
humana y más musical vamos a darle un
aplauso
un aplauso acá ya nuestra niña invitada
por favor que allí también para acá para
que acá ya
vamos a hacer acá un salón de música
super rápido entonces vamos a poner acá
nuestros instrumentos musicales entonces
allí está vamos a tocar un poco ustedes
imagínense nos vamos a transportar aún a
una pequeña aula de música
vamos a transformar este espacio de
conferencias este teatro en una en una
aula de clases en un lugar para
divertirnos para jugar entonces vamos a
tocar un poco
[Música]
vamos a empezar a tocar un poco sobre la
pista
empezamos con 2.2 puntos 3/4
bien
[Música]
e
a
[Música]
e
o no
[Música]
por favor
no lo es